[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by the one and only Jade warshaw and
we're taking your calls at
8825 5225
I know y'all are dming us all your
questions and I say call the ramsy show
okay I can't sit here all day in the DMS
this is where we answered the world's
questions so call us up and we will help
you Zachary has chosen to do so to kick
us off he's in Madison Wisconsin what's
going on
Zachary hey how's it going good how are
you good good I was just calling to get
some input um I'm currently a travel
nurse
and uh we we don't have like a
retirement plan for travel nurses and my
wife she doesn't have a retirement plan
and we don't have any debt right now we
have about 200,000 in
savings um and we don't have much of
retirement and we were looking to buy a
house but we didn't know whether to just
put all of our monies that we have in
savings into our retirements or to try
and buy a
house we had right now we have a Roth
IRA I have about 50,000 in that and then
she has like maybe 20,000 in hers okay
how old are you
to uh 29 and she's 28 great well the
good news is you guys got plenty of time
to build wealth and the fact that you
have this amazing Foundation no debt and
200 Grand tells me that you're on to
something here so uh your your luck is
not lost and those Ro Roth IRAs are
retirement plans so you do have those
options at the very least right now
while you're doing this travel nursing I
imagine imagine you're going to
eventually be in a more stable situation
with
work yeah hopefully this year and so
then you have you'd have retirement
plans
right yeah for me not for her she works
for a South African company so she
doesn't get any
benefits but so you may have different
options in the future for now maxing out
those Roth IRAs is a great move I'm
guessing you have uh six figure income
what's the household
income um about 60,000 between both of
us now the rates are going down for
travel nurses so yeah well that's still
going to be plenty of money that you
could be investing and the way we look
at home ownership versus investing
you're kind of in this baby step 3B so
you want to be you could be investing
you could just put all this into a house
I would recommend a mix of
both have you okay okay have you looked
in your area do you kind of have your
eye on what you might want and do you
know what it
costs um well I'm looking for like uh
$350,000 my wife keeps sending me ones
for like
500,000 well I mean trying to talk her
out of the sky at the end of the day you
know the the guidelines that we teach is
you want to go in looking for a 15-year
fixed rate conventional mortgage and you
don't want the payment to be any more
than 25% of your take-home pay so that's
kind of what your aim is and you know if
you were looking if you were looking to
put $150,000 down on a 350 $50,000 house
I'm sure you'd be just fine um because I
do want you to keep you said you had
200,000 saved I do want to make sure
you're saving Out 3 to six months of
expenses and that you're not thinking
hey I'll just dump this whole 200,000
into a mortgage because you know houses
come with
upep what was that I said houses come
with upkeep and AC's go out and the the
roof gets busted and water leaks in the
kitchen and so you want to make sure you
go in with three to six months of
expenses into that just as an emergency
fund there and do you recommend U moving
over any of our like save money so the
retirement doesn't include it's not
included in that 200,000 so it's all
liquid in the 200,000 you recommend
setting any of that aside to put into
like a longer term retirement I mean you
could max out your Roth IRAs that's
7,000 for each of you so that's 14,000
right there you could but you don't have
to too I mean you guys are 29 if you if
you said to yourself listen I'm going to
like I said I'm going to keep out 40,000
of this for uh 36 months of emergency
and from this point on I'm investing
15% you could do that how long did it
take you to save the 200,000 I'm curious
cuz kind of as a rule of thumb we also
say if it's going to take you more than
two or three years to save up a down
payment you should probably start
investing something so how long did it
take you to save this
200,000 um about 4 years just because of
the travel nursing money in like that
I'm kind of with George I'm in George's
Camp I would definitely set aside I
think there's just a nice mix here if
you took 40 for your emergency fund put
14k max out the roths and the rest can
become your down payment that leaves you
with 146 to put down and then you can
start crunching these numbers to go hey
we can afford a $400,000 house right now
or we can wait another 6 months and bump
up to 450 if we keep saving and so you
guys are in a position where you have
those kinds of options but uh I would at
least start the search and you can get
connected with a Ramsey trusted real
estate agent uh who sells a whole bunch
of houses and they know what they're
doing in this weird wild Market uh even
in your area in Wisconsin and they can
help you get this get your homework
going to see what you can actually
afford and even start getting some some
game plan of what you're going to do and
what you're going to buy
yeah I appreciate it yeah do you have
the 200,000 in high yield savings right
now uh I have 98,000 on high yield
savings and 35,000 in like a mutual fund
and then another 34,000 in Robin Hood oh
boy get it out of Robin Hood yes you
about to get Hoodwinked by Robin Hood my
man oh man know that app makes it so
easy those apps are made to take your
money not make it so be careful I would
move it all to high yield savings
including your emergency fund and you
could be making four to 5% guaranteed
without making a stupid decision indeed
because of an app notification which
ain't bad especially if you're not ready
to pull the trigger on anything in the
next several months like listen you may
as well put it somewhere where you can
get a little return on it every Grand
that sits there for a year you made
5,000 so okay pretty good couch money
right there my friend yeah okay all
right I'll start looking into it thank
you guys guys EAS my nerves on it I
appreciate it you bet happy to snap you
out of the uh paralysis analysis that
can happen I mean what a problem to have
200 Grand sitting there we want to buy
house we know we should be investing but
hey no debt to pay off listen that's a
good place to be in I gives you
different options a much better
situation to be in as opposed to I'm in
debt I'm $200,000 in debt my house is
too expensive I don't have anything
saved in retirement which we hear that
every other call I just I I got a DM
speaking of which on Instagram this guy
was like hey here's our situation we
have these goals where we have no debt
except the mortgage and I said what's
the mortgage he said it's a million
dollar wooo and they made 160 which is a
great income but he said 60% of their
take-home pay was going toward the
mortgage that's known as house poor
exactly and so that's what happens when
people make these decisions before they
should cuz they got a little star eyed
while Zillo yes and they went well wo is
me the housing Market's crazy let's just
buy our dream home now yeah and the
dream home becomes a nightmare that
don't do that that's I can't breathe
thinking about a million doll mortgage
with 160,000 income for sure 60% of your
money out the door that's called living
to work that's middle class fancy right
there that's living to work not working
to live 100% looks good to the outside
world but you can't even breathe inside
of that box that's costing you way too
much to live in I wouldn't leave my
house I'm like I pay too much of my
morgage to ever leave yeah no i' I'd be
up and out of that move with patience my
friends out of debt with the emergency
fund then get a solid down payment do
this so that it's a blessing not a
burden this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys you know this but I'll say it
anyway college is freaking expensive and
student loans are out of control the
average private student loan debt in
2023 was
$55,000
so if you're in overy head with private
student loan debt don't beat yourself up
look we've all made mistakes with money
in the past what matters is doing
something about it now so if you're in
distress with private student loans
that's private not federal student loans
call Y refi y refi refinances defaulted
private student loans that other places
won't touch and gives you a custom loan
built for you based on your ability to
pay to learn more about this custom
refinancing option call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw this
hour and we're taking your calls atle
5225 Chris is up next in Cincinnati
Chris welcome to the ramsy
show hey thank you thank you for taking
my call absolutely how can Jade and I
help um so my wife and I are expecting
our first baby in
July yeah super excited um and we've
been paying off debt uh very
consistently putting back a lot of money
um we are looking to get rid of the
motorcycle that I currently own um which
I am upside down on and in our order of
that it would
be second to the house um so I was
wondering if I should since we were
trying to get rid of it if I should skip
the credit card and truck payment and
move straight to that and chip away at
it or if I should just continue to
follow uh the order I would follow the
order I mean the the point of listing
the debts from smallest to largest is
not it's more psychological than it is
me getting my hands on more money at at
in one moment um because you want to
feel those wins my question for you is
this motorcycle what do you owe on it
and what is it
worth
um so I I blame myself for this but it
it is worth 177,000 and I owe about 31
Oh Lordy my goodness
gracious okay what's the payment on it
just
curious uh
694 oh my Lord okay what's the truck
worth uh the truck is worth 30,000 and
what do you owe on
that uh about 30,000 let's get rid of
that truck this pose is an interesting
conundrum here you got another
car uh we have a Jeep Wrangler that is
paid off we're getting rid of the truck
what's the truck
payment uh the truck payment is 575 oh
golly my G golly G willikers like this
is crazy um and what's left is the
credit cards is that
it uh yeah one we we just paid off One
credit card we only have one left mhm uh
which has about
$4,300 on it okay okay so that's your
your small
instantly yeah you have any
savings uh we have about 10 grand sa
good here's George Let's see if we're on
the same page you've got a Jeep um are
do you both you and your wife work
outside the
home uh yes okay I think this is
possible cuz especially when you don't
have kids yet and your wife wife is
probably going to be going on maternity
leave if if not already soon here um I
would sell this truck for
$330,000 and you've got 10K I would
throw that towards if you wanted to just
pick up a cash car if you needed it you
could but you don't necessarily have to
because I have a sneaking suspicion mom
is going to have a baby she's going to
be at home for a little while they can
probably make the one car thing work for
a while he could knock out this $4,300
credit card and have some money to put
towards the upside down of this
motorcycle for when he does sell it yeah
with the baby on the way here's I'm
really trying to think what I would do
in your shoes oh you do have the baby
the way if you sell the truck I like
what Jade's saying is we're going to use
the 10K and maybe take six of that and
get a used
car for now okay for you to get around
in you leave her with the Jeep um until
baby's here and then stack up cash until
baby and mom are home safe once that
happens you may have enough to get rid
of this upside down
motorcycle okay once baby and mom are
home safe and you've got a bunch of
money stacked in
savings right so that's probably what I
would do in that order um and if you
could find an even cheaper car I'd love
you to knock out the credit cards and
then just stack up money until mom and
baby are home listen George is being
nice cuz I would tell you to go with one
car I I'm just I would never tell you to
do something I never did and when I was
pregnant we had one car cuz we sold the
other one so I'm just saying it's a
option to you it just depends on how
quickly you want to and you know can she
drop you at work and you know do that
whole rig a roll carpool whatever you
got to do to get by for a little while
mhm so you've got some options you've
got options keeping the toys with wheels
that's not one of them what's your
household
income uh it's I think in 23 it was just
over 100 Grand love it
of us and is she going to continue
working outside the home after babies
here um I not like right away obviously
but I think that her plan is to
eventually return she's a nurse in a
nursing home um and I believe her game
plan is to go back to work okay cool are
you guys doing any investing right
now uh no no I I wasn't sure if we
should you shouldn't not yet you're
right just want to make sure you weren't
cuz if you were you pause that and that
would free up some money as
well okay yeah man I think this this
truck is going to free you up of that
575 you can then start throwing into
savings yeah and think how quickly you
could I mean the 10,000 aside because
and there is a world where you just keep
that 10K sitting there until the baby's
born you don't do anything um and that's
probably the best choice here but even
with that 575 cleared up think how
quickly you know once baby is born and
once everything's you know back up and
running think how quickly you could pay
off this credit card close the gap on
that motorcycle there's just it it's so
much money you know that and even just
if they did this today 6 months without
that payment is 3500 bucks exactly so
that's at least as much as you could
save just by getting rid of the payment
making no other
sacrifices right okay um
so it would be smart then to once that
is all out of the way what you guys just
talked about um to chip away at the bike
and tell it's down to what it's worth
and just sell it and break even as far
as yeah me the other option you could do
is go out take a the smaller loan
against the difference with a credit
union to get out from under the sooner
yeah leaving you with a 13 14k loan cuz
you don't even need the motorcycle you
don't need it for transportation so you
don't need to go get another one so at
least you'll be 14,000 in debt instead
of 31,000 in debt right that's going to
make your snowball a lot bigger payment
wise too so I would go down to your
local credit union and see if they would
give you the amount for the upside down
portion but just to clarify the the the
key to press go on all this when you put
the keys in the ignition is when the
baby comes home safe that's that's when
we're turning the keys to start to start
doing real things
right right yeah okay yep sweet I love
it great yeah congrats you know I want
to give you guys a little uh
baby moon gift if you will I'm going to
gift you guys Financial Peace University
and every dollar to give you guys a
little bit of Hope a little pep in your
step as you make this journey grueling
journey of not only getting rid of this
debt but also third trimester that's a
real one that's a real one man Temper
Temper flare George there's a lot of
emotion that geared toward me any man
yeah not just you George wasn't you say
I enjoy the nesting phase cuz I like
organizing so I was like finally game on
she's ready let's do this thing listen I
feel sorry for just about any man in the
in the third trimester it's real you
know what I did enjoy was she got real
into sugar in that third trimester and
so it was like ice cream and Oreos again
but don't eat hers because then it's
Atomic status I learned that I need to
get my own pint get your own husband's
this is a real advice like you're here
for the financial advice but you stay
for the third trimester advice yes do
not dip your spoon into her ice cream
that is lesson learned but that is a
good financial piece that people don't
think about we call it stor and storm
mode that's right only time to pause the
baby steps pause the dead snowball is if
you're in a major storm I'm not talking
about a flat tire I'm talking about a
major medical event a job loss we got to
go hey we got to pause and save up and
babies fall into that category uh
because when things go right it's
wonderful but it's when you the medical
bills start to stack up and you were in
the hospital for more weeks than you
thought and you know you didn't think
about Insurance not paying out 100%
that's right and what you're deductible
and out of pocket max is and so all of
that adds up yeah because in his case to
only I mean 10,000 saved sounds like a
lot of money but if your deductible is
$5,000 you know you're going to hit it
when you have a baby so it's worth
talking about you know making sure
you've at least at the very least got
that deductible in cash ready to go
because you're going to be handing out
some cash when you have a baby before
you hit that Max and you go thank God
it's on the insurance company now that's
important more of your calls coming up
AA 25
5225 this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys ramsy solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switched to netw Suite it works for us
and it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million dollar company
Net Suite can scale with you and help
you communicate and plan better because
you know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not Tech Savvy that
can be okay netw Suite will help at your
speed and whatever your situation more
than 37,000 companies use netsuite to
know their numbers and their business
better so check out netsuite today and
find out how they can help you become
the business you want to be 5 or 30
years from now and right now you can
download Net's free kpi checklist
designed to give you consistently
excellent performance at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm George camel joined by Jade warshaw
our question of the today is brought to
you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services go to neighborly
docomo their winter maintenance
checklist it's free and it's full of
tips to get your home through the colder
months with no issues again you can
check it out at neighborly decom Ramsey
all right today's question comes from
Lucas in Kentucky he says I'm 18 years
old and earn $42,000 a year I got into
an accident this week and total my
Camaro I'm expecting the insurance
settlement will be about $10,000 and I
still owe $60 $300 the problem is I want
a new car don't we all I'm into muscle
cars aren't we all and found a 2023
Mustang for about
$46,000 I bet you did yeah I know it's a
lot but I can get a loan at 7% interest
in 84 months with payments of $650 a
month my parents said it's too much
thank you parents for what I'm making
and for being so young I'd like a second
opinion from you listen we'll give you a
second opinion a third fourth and fifth
cuz I'm sure the booth guys probably uh
agree with us Jade might give you more
than an opinion it might be a whooping
by the end of this one I want this is
not a good situation I would there's
nothing I would love more than to to put
a whooping on Lucas but he's 18 and you
know he needs a little did they stop
teaching basic math in school did we
just like skip to the Pythagorean
theorem and calculus cuz many cases yes
like making 42,000 and you're going to
buy a depreciating asset that's worth
$46,000 doesn't see it that way though
he sees it as I'm making 42k I live at
home I have no bills i' you know the
world is my oyster and I can easily make
a $650 payment that's what he sees and
so I get it but ask for an opinion he's
like the problem is I want a new car we
all want a new car and even we all love
muscle cars like nobody looks at a
Camaro and goes I hate that I prefer my
cars flabby without muscle that's right
if if if you're offered if you win the
prices right you're offered a 2023
Camaro everybody's going to be happy
with that so here's the confusing part
though he says I know it's a lot but I
can get a loan at 7% interest for 84
months and the payments will be
650 this is some kind of opportunity for
stupid I actually did the math for him
Jade what is it he'd be paying get this
over $122,000 in interest alone he
didn't think about that so this $46,000
car you're really buying a $58,000 car
oh my word making 42 and by the way once
you pay it off it ain't worth close to
58 it's probably worth 25 that's a good
fact because new cars on average lose
60% of their value in the first five
years that's right that's right goodness
and he's going to sign on to an 84 Monon
you know what's funny they these car
dealerships are so smart Jade they talk
they talk about loans like they're
babies it's like how old's your baby
she's 84 months old just say it's a
seven-year car loan CU that makes you
think twice yeah in terms of months for
like I don't know 84 months yeah month
is only 30 days Jade this will fly by I
think he thought he's parlaying this
settlement into a great opportunity he's
like listen I'm getting 10,000 he only
6300 it sounds like after he applies the
it it sound well the way I read it was
he's getting 10,000 he owes 63 so he'll
come away with you know 400 or what
4,000 or whatever yeah that he can use
as a down payment on this car is what
I'm thinking um I don't think it's that
he'll owe
6,300 after the fact but even still oh
my no matter how you slice this um it's
stupid it's it's stupid and I get so
many people think oh I got in an
accident I'll just replace it with a
brand new car and you know for what I've
been through I should be able to get
what I want you know and that's not it
if you've got $3,700 or 4,000 bucks just
buy a car in cash and slowly trade up
think of this as an opportunity to not
go into debt again um cuz I'm guessing
the Camaro that you had before clearly
you had payments on it because you know
you have he owes money so let's let's
look at this Lucas as an opportunity to
kind of break that debt cycle and see
what life is like without a car payment
think about all the things you could do
my guess like I said before is you're
living at home think how quickly you
could save for the car that you want
making $42,000 a year at 18 inste trying
to level jump I wish I was making 42 at
18 yeah this kid's very smart in a lot
of ways he is very smart in a lot of
ways but you have to be ultimately smart
that you don't kind of go oh you know
get too big for your Brites and think
listen I'm doing good for myself I can
just jump into debt because debt is it's
interesting when I was that age I
remember thinking people who had car let
me be real I thought people who leased
cars were like balling balling W to be a
baller that's what I thought I'm like if
you're leasing a car if you've got a
credit card and you've got like a like a
$15,000 limit I thought that that's what
you were supposed to Aspire to and I
learned the hard way that all that is is
a facade and what's behind it is stress
anxiety
payments inability to get ahead I
guarantee their Instagram bio says
entrepreneur and I'm like okay you're
unemployed and you live with your
parents bro like let's not pretend right
like that you own owning a vending
machine is you being an entrepreneur
okay I mean goodness gracious y' you
sound like you're talking about somebody
specific I swear some days I wonder like
am I a boomer that accident was put into
a millennial body a little bit but
that's okay I'm right there with you
days anyways Luc off my lawn don't do
this please don't do this you make 42k a
year save up and pay cash get you a
little hoopdee until you can upgrade and
cash that's what I did but uphill both
ways that's what good job George good
job it wasn't long ago I was driving a
$6,000 old Civic bumper half hanging off
and I was proud of that thing that's
good you pay cash for I had goals I love
it so there you go there's there's your
question answered Luc
if that really is your name all right
moving on to the phone lines Bethany is
in Salt Lake City Bethany how are you
doing today good how are you doing great
how can we
help um so we just very recently found
out that I'm pregnant and yeah thank you
we're we're definitely planners so um so
far what we've been doing is we've been
trying to put all of our savings into
various thinking funds but mostly
focusing on a deposit for a house but
now that I'm pregnant I'm wondering if
should we totally pause on the house and
only focus on building like a baby
sinking funds and the health like our
health bills funds or should I equally
doing all of them I'm just not quite
sure what to do the baby is definitely
priority in my book uhhuh and that may
delay the dream of home ownership it may
not we just have to wait and see but are
you guys debt free with an emergency
fund right now where are you at
financially yes so we're we're debt free
we're a single um income household my
husband works um we have about four
months St Saed on the emergency fund and
about 25 Grand in our uh home Co so
those are separate funds yeah okay I
just continue to save up and that all
becomes Savings in general and then once
baby and you are home safe we can
unpause the the dream and see where
we're at with our savings account and if
you've got I'd want six months with a
single income family I'd bump that
emergency fund to six months then
whatever's left over becomes your down
payment
fund so we should take money out of the
the home like I figure I mean I'm not
far along now so I figured we'll try and
do what we can but if we get closer
should we take money out of the home
fund to put in those other places to
make sure you have a six-month emergency
fund yeah yeah it's just a matter of
labeling it differently right okay
because the money is the money you got
50 grand total whether it's 25 and 25 or
30 and 20 you know the the goal here is
to have six months I would put that in a
separate high yield savings and then
have a different high yield savings
account or bucket for the homeown
payment
okay does that make sense yeah it does
good well congrats on the baby what's
the due
date um it's going to the end of
September nice fun love it exciting
times excited yeah hope that helps and
hope you guys uh become homeowners one
day as well that's two really fun pieces
of adulting for sure having the kid
getting the house but here's the thing
Jade a lot of people go we have the baby
now we need the room we need it cuz
babies take up so much space it's a tiny
little bassinet in the corner they're
fine my child my first born son who will
remain nameless on here he um we had his
whole bedroom done his crib and
everything he never even was in that
room nobody told me that baby lives next
to your bed for for the first few months
yeah at least six months this Joker
didn't even go in his bed until six or
seven months so so this idea that your
two-bedroom isn't enough because you had
a baby and now we need to upgrade to the
five-bedroom house is crazy yeah it's
crazy it is crazy but it's exciting and
I think you just feel like oh I want to
get the baby new stage yeah that was a
big phase for us we got the board and
batting in the room got it painted a
little blush pink it's very exciting for
me she's never even been up in there has
she she doesn't even know colors yet
let's be real might as well be agreeable
gray to her there you go there's your
Sherwin Williams reference for the day
more of the Ramsay show coming right up
don't go
[Music]
anywhere
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
CM she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Cel joined by Jade warshaw open
phones at
8825 5225 you call us we'll talk about
your money your life whatever is going
on Celeste joins us in guadalahara
Mexico about time Celeste how are you
doing over there Hi um hi nice to meet
you guys um so I'm a grad student right
now I'm visiting my folks um and uh my
question actually uh is about them so
they're asking for um advice on whether
they should take out a loan for a car um
a used car um or whether they should dip
into their savings H why would they why
do you think that they would prefer
having payments over using the cash they
have I so um I guess I'll say it in
pesos um but uh they have about 400,000
pesos saved up and then a new oh well
sorry a used car um a six seveny old uh
car would be about um
250,000 pesos um the reason I say this
is because or they're debating is
because my um this is their pretty much
their only savings account I mean he my
father is the only one who works okay um
my mother does not um they own two cars
uh one of the cars is uh pretty much on
its last legs and my mom is looking for
a job um and trying to find a way to
reliably get to work okay so um yeah so
that kind of stms from that so I think
their worry is that um they would not uh
it's been about five years it took them
five years to accumulate what they have
in savings um you know for to have an
emergency fund um they would have to dip
into why did it take five years do they
have any other
debt they don't have any other debt so
um my they own three properties um
they're all paid off uh both of the cars
are paid off um and uh I don't think my
father wants to um sell any of them so
um I think his idea would be to um use
the money that they have now um and not
take out a loan I think he's pretty
resistant on it now and why are they
asking you about
it um I'm just a concerned bystander
okay so did they bring it up did they
say hey Celeste we're wondering do you
think this is a good idea or did you say
hey I overheard you guys talking about
this I wouldn't do it
uh yeah that's the second one okay so
they didn't ask for your opinion you
just concerned for their financial
wellbeing as a great daughter yes okay
well I just did the conversion uh here
from peso so they have about 23,000 plus
USD yes and they're they're looking to
spend about 14,000 of that
USD yes okay and they would leave them
with 7,000 I mean that's still they can
then rebuild their emergency fund with
the payment they would have been making
on the car they just use that to
replenish the emergency fund yeah and
just on a theoretically speaking I
consider I would consider and again
we're having this conversation with you
not your parents so you're probably
right there with us but if I'm looking
at risk I'm thinking okay going into
debt is creating a bigger risk than
depleting my savings by half to avoid
debt and I almost feel like they've got
the equation swapped and they're
thinking depleting my savings is a
bigger risk than going into debt and
that would be completely wrong because
usually your debt the debts in your life
are what create the emergency feeling
not lack of something goes down it's
like oh I got to pay the debt off I need
the savings so if you don't have debt
you lower your
risk and so right you're you're you're
asking us how do you talk to your
parents about this you could tell them
listen I care about you guys I know
you're not you don't need my opinion but
I care about you guys so much that I'm
begging you not to take out this loan
because it's going to put your future at
risk and you can show them some math
some people need the math some people
need the emotion maybe it's a mix of
both where you say listen this is what
this car is really going to cost you
with interest here's what you could do
with that freed up payment and worst
case he can sell one of the properties
if something huge goes down but my my
bigger concern is why it took him five
years to save up an emergency fund is
the income low well he's got these three
properties
too yeah well one they recently
inherited from my grandmother's passing
um so they're renting that one out um
the my my mother doesn't work um
currently um and my father makes about
50 with the rent from that property um
and his job he makes about 50,000 a
month a month uh in pesos yes okay so
that's about three grand
almost yes okay so that's that's the
part I'm looking at here is okay that's
how many months of his income is he
going to take to buy this car and when
you do that math it's a little more it
puts it into perspective and you go it's
$14,000 divid 3 that's almost five
months of him working to get this car
which is not bad and it tells me in five
more months he can replenish that
money if if he doesn't have a payment
it's going to free them up and if their
expenses are low and these rentals are
cash
flowing hey right yeah I but that would
be minus like whatever monthly expenses
sure they have do they have a lot of
expenses
um not currently both my brother and I
are out of the house so it's mostly just
them right now and you said your mom's
looking for
work she is yeah good so how are you
doing financially because the what I'm
looking at is I'm
thinking uh I'm thinking about my
younger sibling cuz I'm trying to liken
it to what you're at you're the you're
the the kid trying to tell the parents
what to do so I'm thinking okay my
younger brother he's 7 years younger
than me
what would make me take what would make
me take his advice of him saying hey I I
heard you were about to go buy a car
Jade here's what here's what I think you
should do right I'm trying to flip that
on it on its head and think okay what
would I want I'd want him to be doing
better than me financially and I can see
it I'd want to be able to look at him
and go he seems like he's got it
together like he's always talking about
paying cash I've never seen him talk
about debt matter of fact I don't think
he has any debt like I'd want to be able
to visibly observe certain qualities
that make me go this is somebody who has
their financial life together so my
question is how are you
doing right um totally makes sense uh
I'm actually a a graduate student right
now um in the states so um I'm taking
care of myself my brother's in college
um he's also you know putting his way
through school so um I mean I currently
don't have um any debt other than seven
Grand in student loans that is on pause
right now since I'm still in school sure
um so that's kind of where I'm at okay
um you know you can you can attempt this
I don't know what your relationship is
with your with your parents but you know
all you can do is is float it out there
I think like George said you've got to
say it in a way if you're not saying it
in a way that's like here's what I'm
doing um or here's what I've learned
then the chances of it sinking in is
going to be little to none um and I
think the best way that you can relate
it to is probably your own debt and the
mistake you feel around that like if you
say listen I I took out this $7,000
student loan and I'm now realizing it
would have been better for me to pay
cash and here's why and I don't want you
to make that same mistake with this car
payment because I know how I feel and
you guys you
know that's the only way that you're
going to be able to shift this in their
mind as opposed to just saying hey you
should you should really use the money
you have
saved MH right okay that makes sense are
you a Spanish
speaker yes I am you should check out
and have them check out our friend Andre
Gutierrez he's like Spanish Dave he used
to be one of our personalities here and
he does a great job explaining these
Concepts to that community and he has
his own show on YouTube and radio and
his own version of financial peace so be
sure to check that out I think maybe
he'll connect with them better than I
can for sure that's a good point that
could be a good resource for them
absolutely thank you for the
call thank you guys bye
that was a that was a deep cut my man
Andre so I was just thinking about him I
was like man they're talking pesos I'm
doing calculations here we got send to
Andre so you know how Dave does the
scissors with the credit cards he Andre
has a machete so he's got a giant
machete he uses to cut up cards he's got
a wooden block and it's it's so
entertaining and he's a solid dude doing
great things out there in the San Anton
San Antonio area you're telling me he
puts the credit card on a cinder block
goes on wooden thing and the credit card
sits in there and then he'll just swipe
him with machetes that's dramatic it's
very intense that's very intense but you
need intensity to convince people to get
out they we were intense my goodness
there you go that's about as cultured as
I'll get this hour Jade that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books
thank you to my co-host Jade warshaw all
the dudes in the booth we got them all
today Austin Ben James Zack Nathan
Andrew they're all hanging out and thank
you America we'll be back with you
before you know it this has has been the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George campel joined
by Jade warshaw and this is your show
America so call us up atle
88255 225 we will do our best to give
you advice and it's worth what you paid
for it remember that if you don't like
it and don't call in if you if you don't
if you already know what we're going to
say and you don't want to take it don't
waste the a time but if you need that
confirmation to push you over the fence
cuz you know what you need to do we're
happy to give you a little little some
people need to be a little firm they
need to be handled firmly there we go
that's and that's what Jade's here for
she's the muscle I'm just the eye candy
that gets us through it all Michael is
up first in Wilmington North Carolina
Michael welcome to the
show hey thanks y'all thanks for having
me I've been listening to y'all for few
years now and just looking for some
advice um my wife and I bought a house
together in 20122 and she recently
decided that she wanted to divorce and
that she's going to be moving out next
week I'm sorry um I appreciate it me too
um and so I know a bunch of my friends
and family have said that um you know
the only way to be able to um take the
loan over would be to refinance um and I
found out through our mortgage company
that they do have um Assumption of the
loan um process and I was just curious
which which way might be best for me to
go that way I could get the mortgage and
everything um solely in my name yeah
yeah well that's that's great that your
lender has those options a lot of them
the only way to do it is refinance but
again it's always worth asking your
lender to see if they can do a loan
modification or the loan assumption and
it sounds like have you looked into the
terms of that it sounds like it'll be
the cheaper route for you to do a loan
assumption if you can afford it and take
on that risk on your own sure um they
literally just sent um over the email
today um I I'm at work so i' kind of
went through it a little bit um and just
even the numbers from that um you know
like you said it can be kind of pricey
um and so I wasn't quite sure what the
refinance is we haven't touched any of
the equity in it or anything so that's
part of the reason why I was hoping that
you know before I found out about their
assumption details might have been able
to refinance and maybe use um that
equity for the stuff to refinance it um
but when what she owed in this
deal what have you guys gone through the
process well that's what I wanted to ask
are is she going to get a piece of this
home in the equity
mhm um I I don't know um I'm not it's
not like I'm trying to um it's not like
I'm trying to do all this um like behind
her back or or Shady I'm just trying to
try and I guess figure out the best
option um for me because I want to stay
in the house my father is um just been
put on hospice and he lives with me um
so I'm trying to keep the house I just
want to know if you guys like did you
guys say hey we're just going to figure
this out ourselves or are there any
lawyers involved that are saying and
kind of uh mediating this for you and
saying okay here's the deal here's what
it's going to be I just don't want you
to get ahead of yourself and this not be
the terms of the actual divorce if you
go through all this and then it turns
out you have to sell the house or do a
Cash out refinance to pay her portion
anyways and so now you've got two
refinances so that we're just trying to
make sure you know what the next steps
are before you make a big Financial move
like this sure sure no we have not gone
through um anything just yet um as far
as lawyers um or any type of agreement
I've been trying to work with her as far
as some type of agreement um how long
were you
married um the end of February will'll
be two years okay so depending on the I
mean the judge is who's going to decide
what's fair and Equitable here and so
there may be a situation where he goes
listen you guys weren't married enough
to split this half and half here's what
she gets here's what you get you get to
keep the house who knows how it's going
to shake down but I would absolutely uh
work with an attorney even if it's one
in just mediation between you two to get
all this down on paper before we make a
decision what's next yeah I definitely
don't pull the trigger on any of this
yet okay yeah no I appreciate it I just
wasn't sure if if regardless of however
um certain ways went about if there was
a better way um to to handle it if I was
able to assume or if if refinancing was
the better option how much Equity do you
have in the
house um I'm I'm not sure honestly um
normally I was the one just outworking
and putting the money in the accounts
and I let her um handle paying it um
have you guys separated bank accounts
yet um not well we had we have one joint
account um and we had one for the house
um and then we each had our own
individual okay I would SE separate
finances to keep things clean right now
okay and it sounds like you're going to
be paying the mortgage on your own yes
well I have then and how much is the
mortgage compared to your take-home
pay um
the the mortgage is uh
1750 a month and I bring home give or
take for a month wow that's tight tight
tight like a tiger oh so it's almost
half your income going towards this and
if so here's the thing if if let's say
she gets a portion of the equity and you
have to do a Cash out
refinance yeah well that's going to make
your mortgage payment go
up and so I don't know that you're going
to be able to stay in this house based
on how much Equity you have and what
this new mortgage will be I mean you
already kind of can't even if that
weren't a factor yeah sure well I umum
like I said I've been the one who's been
paying for the house ever since we moved
in um I work a full-time and I I try and
pick up some side jobs here and there to
um but that was with her income too
right was she contributing
financially um no not not to um not to
the house so you guys were just really
scraping by then with this well well
what I tried to do was I tried to be the
one um that went out and worked to cover
the bills so that way she could um stay
home and focus on the baby and focus on
school and not have to work you one kid
together yep yeah we just had a son
seven months ago oh I'm sorry so when
you go out and work you said you know
you kind of close that Gap when you go
out and do other jobs what type of jobs
are you doing and what are you bringing
home in addition to your 4,000 a month
well it's not consistent um but um I I
go out and I do Mechanical Services on
the side um so I could bring in anywhere
from I don't know an extra um Grand to
extra three grand a month here's here's
where I'm at listening to what you're
saying and kind of what it's been and
what you're bringing in and the
consistency or inconsistency of it all
with what George is saying as it is I
think that your your mortgage was
already too high assuming she wasn't
contributing much um financially there
and then like George said if you do this
cash out refi is going to cause your
your monthly payment to go up I don't
think that you can handle that you know
you're going to sit and you're going to
talk with a lawyer and you guys are
going to figure this out but if it were
me I probably try to walk away from this
a clean break and get into something
that you can afford monthly that's 25%
of your takehome and is not contingent
what one thing you don't want to do and
this is not just for you but anybody you
don't want to have to side hustle to pay
your mortgage if you're side hustling to
make sure that you can afford your
mortgage payment something's wrong and
you're out of balance it's not
sustainable yeah side hustling is to do
extra things like pay off debt and save
for things not to make sure you can
clear your mortgage hang on the line
we're going to send you a link to our
divorce checklist from our friend Dr
John delone on the Ramsey blog this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window window coverings
from blinds.com can completely change
your space and add value to your home
we've recommended blinds.com for over a
decade so you know you can trust them
from blinds drapes and shutters to
motorized Shades they make it easy and
affordable to upgrade your entire home
and their team is ready to help with
everything from design consultation to
measuring and installation plus there
are never any m leading quotes or hidden
fees everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Jade warshaw friendly reminder
cuz we just went out during the break to
the lobby and met some wonderful people
from all over the country you can come
visit us and watch the show live if
that's that's your form of entertainment
is to watch people through glass sit at
a desk and do a show that you could
listen to on podcast we'd love to have
you and people travel from all over just
to hang out with us we got two birthdays
in the crowd today Jade this is how they
wanted to celebrate and George gives out
hugs to every single person that's well
I joke that if you hug me I'll break
like I'm that weak and sensitive so be
careful I go down easy well Jade we both
love food we do and we both talk about
money and so we thought what if we did a
fun little segment on this show called
tacky or hacky yes and this is where I
throw out something that people do maybe
that we've done and you got to give your
take if it's a if it's tacky or if it's
kind of a money hack I'm ready so this
is restaurant Edition today restaurant
Edition you ready for this okay and you
guys at home if you're listening
wherever and you're with someone or you
want to talk to yourself you let us know
is this tacky or hacky taking extra
stuff from restaurants for your house
napkins condiments plastic utensils do
you think I'm going to mostly go with
tacky I think there's a line here all
right uh were they given to me yes or am
I just grabbing a whole handful of
condiments for the road right I was at
Chipotle yesterday I'm not taking I only
needed one fork I'm not taking five cuz
they have they have the nice plastic
forks I will say Chipotle's utensil game
on point it's sturdy right and I didn't
take I will say sometimes I take a few
extra napkins for the car not for my
home yeah but I'm willing to admit that
that's a tacky I I don't like Chipotle's
napkins going to be honest like the
brown cardboard napkins Brown we can do
better even for a car situation so I'm
going to go I'm going to go mostly tacky
and it's hcky if it was given to you or
if you're taking a reasonable amount now
I will save the Chopsticks from do you
know cuz they usually give you maybe one
extra one and it's nice to keep it in
the drawer just just in case one time
you order and they forget that's fair
that's that's that's that's hacky we've
got that all right next up ordering your
drink with no ice I'm assuming in order
to get more liquid I'm going to go hacky
on that one hacky been there done that
that's not tacky at all and it it avoids
it from just getting super watered down
if it takes you a while to drink it now
this depends on the kind of drink I mean
some people I feel like with a fountain
drink you need some ice in there it's
just strange without it and you can
always refill it you know what I mean so
it depends on the beverage well let's
add an outlier here because there people
go to extremes I might know someone in
my family who would save a cup and bring
it in the next day bring back for a free
refill and get a free refill that to me
is
tacky that's beyond the the moral line
for me personally so are you calling my
family members tacky I'm not going to
report them I'm just saying if I did
that my wife would be like really oh
most definitely you know I mean there'd
be some eye rolls yeah that's extended
family by the way not Sam warshaw okay
next up kids meals for older kids SL
teenagers I'm going I'm going hacky I'm
going to go hacky
because I mean smaller portion cheaper
price probably the correct portion but
what about if the menu says like 12 and
12 and below it doesn't matter even if
the menu says 12 or below I like here's
the thing I still to this day I'll go to
Chick-fil-A and I'll order a kids
meal and not one time have they been
like sir is there a children in the
vehicle with you does it but I don't
think it says that on their menu but if
you go to a restaurant it'll say on the
kids menu like 12 and Below now the
fancier the restaurant the less likely I
am to do this you know what I mean yeah
but if I don't need a I mean some of
these portions Jade you've seen them
Gargantua I'm like y'all we're eating
for three over here MH you know I got us
a little physique I don't need that much
wow okay so I think it's it's hacky in
most situations but again if they say
hey kids only I go all right no no big
deal I'm not going to put up a stink
about it what about okay again sorry I'm
going rogue a little bit James cuz it's
making me think of like trifling things
that I've seen people do who shall
remain nameless all right you go to the
Mexican restaurant they bring chips to
the table that are usually free it comes
with a meal Y and you're really done
with the chips but you're like I'll
order another basket and I'll take those
home oh the to go chips
scenario all right I'll go hacky on that
one is that
hacky I think I would say tacky on that
I I don't I wouldn't do it just to take
it to go I would get the chips and be
like all right I'm really done with the
chips here my entree is here and these
chips are going to go to waste you know
they're going to throw them out one
would hope so you're saying it's the
motivation behind it if you didn't know
there was going to be leftovers you take
them but you don't order it knowing
you're not going to eat they don't
recycle the chips off the table do they
yes they do yes I got trust issues now I
used to work on a cruise ship let me
throw this out here I used to work on a
cruise ship you know you go out at any
restaurant they give you a a basket of
bread yeah if you could and you know you
rifle through it to pick the piece of
bread you want they will 100% save that
bread and put it in somebody else's
basket you're welcome now it's gross I
know is that just cruise ship I'm going
to go with that's in everyday life
George I feel like the restaurants that
I frequent they wouldn't do that they're
too classy and there's there's OSHA
violations there's too many issues that
could go wrong Sam and I went to a
restaurant a couple of night uh a couple
weeks ago and it was fairly nice and
when they brought out the Bread Basket I
could tell it had a lot of crumbs in it
there was a piece that looked like had
been broken off of the lavache I was
like ah I'm not getting a good vibe
about this Bread Basket well to be fair
I told you guys don't go to Applebees
after 10 p.m. and you did it anyways you
did it anyway well played George camel
okay let's keep going on this well play
all right next up splitting meals hacky
your tacky okay I do this so I think
it's hacky I don't think it's tacky you
here's where it gets hacky and tacky
don't tell them you're going to split it
because some restaurants they'll charge
you plate so don't tell them just eat it
off each other's plate yeah well I like
to get an entree my wife will get an
entree and then we'll kind of eat half
and switch or something and some
restaurants I mean like we'll get
fajitas at one of these local Mexican
places it's tons of food in a fajita for
one and my wife and I split that and we
have a great time so I don't think
there's anything wrong with that I'm not
doing anything immoral okay but what
about this uh alcoholic beverage if you
will splitting one of
those I mean that's strange cocktails
are expensive at a restaurant y I
wouldn't split a I'm trying to think of
you know I wouldn't split a
soda maybe a glass well the one thing I
have free refills though so you could
split one yeah but then the server
that's too t that's tacky that's tacky
splitting a soda so you get free refills
and then you each can have your fill of
cuz you're trying to avoid paying
another three bucks for your soda but I
think a cocktail is fine cuz those are
wildly expensive there's no free refills
on cocktails and some people might not
want to handle a full drink okay so that
one's fair if it's alcoholic if it's not
I think it's a little tacky well tacky
all right next up ordering an appetizer
or dessert only hcky yeah I don't know
what what's wrong with that money now
here's the thing the real is skip the
apps and dessert and get the entree what
I do well here's where the motivation
part of it comes in like what was your
motivation going in so when you're
getting out of debt right and you're
like I'm not going to spend a lot of
money and your friends are going out but
you're like I'm not going to go out and
spend money I'll just go for the company
there's always a friend that feels bad
and it's like you know I got yours I'll
get yours so if you say yes and you're
like I'm just going to get I'm just get
the soup or I'll just get the side salad
or I'll get a water and then you're
dipping your little rubby hands into
those fries that we got oh you know hey
there's another move I think if you're
just honestly like I'm going out this is
all I want definitely hacky but if you
have a motivation you know what's tacky
though and I've been in this situation
is people go well we'll just split it
all evenly it'll be easier and then I'm
like whoa who I didn't get the appetizer
or the three cocktail I got water and
one Entre I'm like hold up you're not
splitting this evenly I know that's
right I'm like tacky to be the person
who says Let's just split it evenly when
you got the most that that's because
it's always the Michael Jordans and the
LeBron that say that and I'm over here
the sixth man I may not make what they
make I'm Muggsy Bogues out here you know
what I mean the six man does not make
what the point guard the starting point
guard makes and so when you're out to
dinner with your friends you got to play
you got to think about that before you
say hey let's just all split it and you
go order the filet yarn George like you
did I'm just kidding that's fair okay
last one getting soda at the soda
fountain when you didn't order a soda so
you got the cup for water that's legit
stealing that's tacky that's tacky but
you know what I have done is the right
next to the water there's a soda button
there's no syrup it's just soda water
all right I'll do that with a cup of
water it's still water listen no syrup I
didn't cost the company any money with
they're paying for syrup for the ogs you
already know you order water and lemons
and go ahead and put your own I make my
own little lroy like Chipotle get the
soda water I squeeze a lime in there you
got a lime lroy for free okay so there's
your Chipotle hack listen I think that
it's tacky
but thank you Jade this has been tacky
or hacky restaurant Edition hope you
guys enjoyed that and budget for it
whether it is tacky or
[Music]
hacky
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage AG over those other
guys go to Churchill mortgage.com today
to learn
[Music]
more you're listening to the ramsy show
I'm George camel joined by Jade War the
phone number to call is
5225 David is up next in Burlington
Vermont David welcome to the
show hey guys thank you so much for
having me sure how can we help today so
I have a small problem it seems like
compared to some of the other callers
but um I am getting I run a small
AutoGlass business here in Vermont um it
is new it's about 7 months old and I'm
looking to I got a little bit of money
back in taxes or I'm getting money back
about $2,000 worth um the problem is is
I do have some credit card debt um I
have about $2,800 in credit card debt um
and so I'm assuming what you're going to
tell me is to just pay the credit card
debt but I do have an opportunity to
invest the money into um the business
for the calibration systems that I need
to do or need to use in the industry um
so I just don't know if I should just
pay off the debt immediately or if I
should invest it into the business h
well you're right you may not like our
answer but do you do you have 800 bucks
in savings as well in cash in the
bank I don't okay I've been I've pretty
much thrown every you know every bit of
money I have into into the business yeah
at this point well to me that's the more
glaring problem is that you are on thin
ice already my friend as far as this
business and your cash flow and your
personal financial world and so before
you put another dime into this business
we've got to become debt free and then
cash flow one once we're debt free once
we have an emergency fund to then grow
this business how long can you get by
without the calibration
systems uh well that's the thing so
right now I'm subbing the calibrations
out um to other shops so I'm I'm I'm not
essentially losing money but it's money
I could be making um right now I'm
getting by um the issue isn't isn't
getting by it's just you know making
more profit um you know seeing the
potential to make more profit are you
working full-time at this business I am
yes okay are you able to take on a
hustle while it gets off the ground to
bring in some more income right now what
is this bringing in for you
net I'm that's the thing it's it's I to
be completely honest I haven't I haven't
even tracked it I know I'm I'm I'm
making enough to pay the bills and
that's it okay is this just
you it is yes okay are okay okay you
said seven months old are you putting
aside since you're not really taking
inventory are you putting aside for
quarterly and for
taxes uh yeah so so the taxes are are
handled um I actually just had a huge
scare with the state um and they thought
I ow $26,000 and I okay was able to
resolve that luckily but yeah so right
now that the tax isn't the issue okay
good um I listen I'm with George um I
would a start getting a handle on what
you are making because you you got to
understand if your business is doing
well and what it's doing because then
you might look at the numbers and go I I
should be able to pay for this out of
the business and not my taxx return you
know but I do think that you should pay
off this credit card debt
first okay even though the credit card
uh debt is more personal versus the
business everything's personal man guess
who sign those business
documents David gotcha okay so yeah
there's really no such thing as business
it's all in your name and therefore you
owe it all and so I want you to have as
little risk as possible run this
business debt-free I love that you're
wanting to cash flow these systems but
you'll get there once we have more
financial footing and Foundation underne
us mhm good gotta okay thank you so much
yeah I would pause on this even though
you could be making money any
opportunity to do something that puts
you at risk is not an opportunity MH and
whether that's going into debt or
investing in the business when you have
debt it's all the same and you've got to
get that emergency fund in place ASAP
but I hey I'm glad you know you get a
refund instead of owing $26,000 that is
quite the scare and I know it's taxes
and a lot of people out there J now
filing and getting their documents
together I want to let them know we have
a great free resource at Ramy
solutions.com
tax and on that site you'll see my my
pretty face along with Dave's extra
pretty face and we'll help you figure
out number one is it worth filing with a
pro or can you do it on your own with
tax software we also have some really
great free resources I use these every
year I go to the site and I download the
personal checklist for taxes and it has
every single document I could need I
love that go through that and I pull it
online log the site and I can knock it
out uh in a real short amount of time
there's also a really great beginners
guide to taxes that is super helpful how
to income taxes work what do you need to
know for the 2024 tax season how to file
what about deductions and credits how to
choose a tax adviser filing an extension
the truth about tax refunds it's all
right there I can't believe it's free
Jade and so go to Ramsey solutions.com
SL tax to get all of those resources I
promise you it's going to give you it's
going to help you burn less brain
calories this tax season that's so true
have you filed yet have you I I got my
appointment to file and I've got all my
documents ready in on my computer in a
folder everything's labeled perfectly my
wife is like how do you know all this
I'm like I don't I'm just a giant there
was a glimmer in your eye just now when
you were talking about it I'm not going
to lie like spending 3 hours on a
Saturday doing that was somehow
invigorating it was like cleaning out a
closet you know what I mean just feels
good once you're done satisfaction I get
that all right there we go we're moving
on to Philadelphia Matt joins us there
what's going on
Matt hi how you guys doing great how are
you um good uh so I just started
listening to the program about six
months ago or so um and I have a general
question on finances and then another
question on potentially getting married
um uh so I'm following the program not
not perfectly but I'm trying uh I have
down about $3,000 in credit card debt um
my biggest debt is actually I have to
pay back visually impaired and I to pay
back Social Security a substantial
amount about
$80,000 um but that debt is actually
interest free um so I've been just
paying the agreed payment basically and
and attacking uh my credit card and my
mortgage which is down to about uh
$73,000 I've kind of been paying them
both I know that's not the exact way to
do it I'm just about to get rid of the
credit card debt but my main question
was with with all that um I'm still
investing through work uh 6% because
they match uh the 6% should I be
stopping that completely until yes the
debt is gone yeah um you know you said
you listen to what we teach and you're
not doing it perfectly I don't I don't
think you're really doing it at all in
our way I think that you have in your
mind that you want to pay down your debt
but the way that we would teach to do
this is is very different than what
you're doing that so I'd like to kind of
call out the major differences but I
think you know what they are
what's your income I guess it's just
just a hes uh 64k okay I mean right now
you're paying off your mortgage along
with your other debts which we would
tell you that's further on down the line
baby step one you get $1,000 saved first
and then baby step two you pay off all
your Consumer Debt everything except the
mortgage so you're really flip-flopping
it um do you have the $1000 Saved By the
way yes how much do you have
saved uh around 4,000 you can knock out
the credit card debt today I want to
call out the fact that you're really not
doing our plan at all even a little
bit my my main concern was I have to
have like a some some housework done
like a roof on the garage and I wanted
to save a little cash to potentially pay
the person to do it in cash rather than
okay so it's like a sinking
fund that's my that's my safety now I
guess at this point that's the only
reason I haven't done how urgent is that
roof over the garage is it like falling
apart uh
it's not falling apart it's it's got a
slow leak I mean if you had to say
what's the what's the timeline on this
thing uh I need to get it done soon I
was kind of waiting for the winner to
get over but probably in the next month
or two okay so okay I got What's it
gonna
cost that's a good question I'm not
really sure I'm thinking somewhere
around 1500 to 2,000 okay okay so you've
got a little extra there find out
exactly what it is because this is money
all this money when you just kind of
keep it around in hordes not to say that
you have lots of it but it's money that
could could be going to work for you so
if this thing is only going to cost
$1,500 or $1,100 you've got another
$1,300 here that could be helping you
right now so let's get a clear estimate
on that I want you to stop investing I
understand that you're getting 6% but
that's a lot of money that could be back
in your pocket for you to be paying off
these credit cards and really paying off
this social security I'm not sure you
probably don't have to go into it but
I'm not sure how that happened but
$80,000 is a lot of money regardless of
it's interest free it is a weight on
your body and I want you to get that
paid off so I want you to stop on the
mortgage wait until baby steps six which
is when you're supposed to do that and
right now I really just want you focused
on paying off this debt using the debt
snowball and that's how you're going to
do this that's how we teach to do it so
if you want to do our plan that's the
way it goes and freeing up that
investment that's 3,840 bucks a year
that's 320 bucks a month that'll make
you feel some progress instead of doing
17 things at once without making any so
we hope you follow our plan all the way
man that's the only way it works this is
the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw open
phones at
aa825
5225 and while you're enjoying the show
if you could do us a tiny but huge favor
for us hit the share button hit the
follow button hit the Subscribe button
leave a review leave a kind comment send
a link to your mom and say hey Mom I
thought you'd enjoy this show I know my
mom's watching right now is she she
fills me in she's like you need to smile
more only only a mom can get away with
that that's right like you're right Mom
I'm sorry it's a it's kind of a radio
show there's not like a looking at the
camera you know I'm not trying to be
upset you're just focused on listening
to calls for three hours so I'll do
better mom smash that subscribe button
smash it we're doing great thank you you
guys are the marketing plan and it's
free to you this is a free show for you
and we appreciate you being here bill is
in Boston up next bill what's going on
hi guys thanks so much for taking my
call sure um I'm 51 years old single um
I'm a homeowner with
$50,000 left in the mortgage uh value of
750,000 in the house awesome had a
retirement of
157,000 I started all over 12 years ago
when I got
divorced um I've got about saving I've
got uh 10,000 for savings no credit card
debt no car payment and I have a
Vanguard Target retirement of a 2040
fund as
well you said
240 uh 240 yes it's a Target date fund
okay that goes until 2040 oh 2040 I'm
sorry I misunderstood you okay okay all
right what's your question
today should I be doing anything else uh
the past few years um I've put about
$118,000 into my
pr1k um I just want to get ready I'm
working hard not to have debt I don't do
much do you have anything except the
mortgage as far as debt no sir great and
so if you're following the Ramsay plan
this would put you I know you found us
so let me lay it out for you baby step
one $1,000 emergency fund you're through
that baby step two payoff all Consumer
non-mortgage Debt you're through that
baby step three is 3 to 6 months of
expenses do you have that with the
10,000 or do you need more than that um
my guess is
more if you added up six months of your
expenses to run your house is that going
to I won't have six months would that be
closer to 20 or 25 for you uh yeah it
would be closer to 25 yeah okay so
that's a good goal for you in the
savings and then beyond that once you
have that 25 saved then we can move on
to investing 15% of your income into
retirement how much are you investing
now percentage
wise uh 20 okay so you could dial that
back to 15 and then whatever's left over
you can throw at the mortgage and get
that knocked
out I wasn't yeah I wasn't sure what I
had a feeling you were going to ask me
to back it off a lot just to bang out
the mortgage well you're 51 my goal for
you and I think your best path to wealth
and being secure in retirement is to
have no mortgage payment no debt
whatsoever and have that nest deag
building and so that's can also decrease
your biggest fixed expense what's your
mortgage
payment uh it's it's not much it's just
$500 well without taxes just mortgage
alone is 500 okay plus taxes and
insurance so you'll free up 500 bucks
once you get rid of the mortgage which
will be helpful in
retirement okay so and the good news is
at over you're going to have some catch
up contributions and so once the
mortgage is paid off you can increase
investing to 30 40% of your income and
be maxing out everything oh I didn't
know that so you're able to um
contribute additional money that I'm not
able to at 34 years old but once you're
over 50 you can contribute more to that
401k more to the IRA and so that's going
to help you to build up that nest egg
faster as you race toward
retirement what can you max out at your
401k at 51 let me see the 2024 they just
upped it let me check on that for you
with my handy dandy uh laptop here here
we
go okay I am
seeing H well George looks for that what
kind I'm just kind of curious what set
you on this path to start paying off
your mortgage and doing all of this if
you I see on here that you're kind of
new to Ramsay so what was it just you
realizing I want to start
over uh I just never likeed I got
divorced um I uh I carried a lot of debt
after that and P I'd say four or five
years is when I it took me about seven
years to really finally get out of it
and now I'm able to do the 20% for my
401k you know I want a future I don't
want absolutely well you've got a taste
of the freedom on the other side getting
rid of all that debt too right and I
don't you know I mean I don't do any I
like to fish I like a hunt you know I
know bit of money goes to that but
that's just a few thousand dollars a
year that's my thing yeah you don't
sound like you're living a crazy
frivolous lifestyle here you're doing a
lot of the right things and the uh I I
found the contribution limit for 2024
it's
23,000 and then you get to contribute an
additional 7500 on top of that that's
significant so that's pretty serious
that's you're putting over 30k in that
401k uh as you get in your later years
working what's your
income um depending on over time I would
say average about
85 okay and we've got a great investment
calculator on our website that's free
bill you can jump on there Ramsey
solutions.com and you can start punching
in these numbers and going all right I
have 157 saved right now if that just
grows and I keep contributing you know
500 bucks a month a th000 bucks a month
you can see exactly what you'd have over
time and I think that will be an
encouragement to you uh to go oh okay
I'm going to be okay another 10 years of
compound growth and investing with no
house payment you could have a pretty uh
decent little Nest Egg there and I
imagine you're going to be able to work
in your later years or do you have a
goal in
mind I would love to be 65 okay but I
but I my Social Security I went down to
the office uh two weeks ago and it's 67
for me so if that's it so be it but um
they told me 67 at my age right now is
when I would be able to retire well I
just popped in some numbers for you Bill
uh your 51 at 65 if you keep
contributing to this 157 with 10% return
on average you'd have 1.3 million
sitting in that Nest
T is that okay what is that with what is
what is it that I'm contributing every
year to make that happen that's at1 1875
a month I just put on a random number in
there that's 225 so that's even below
the current limit without your catchup
contributions so at
225 for the for the now until 67 now
until now until
65 now until 65
225 that would be how much 1. what 1.3
million my
friend so start dreaming a lot can
happen in 14 years with a little bit of
consistency and you keep staying on this
plan and you get rid of that mortgage um
but again you got to do these things in
an order because a lot of people Bill
what they do is they try to do 17 things
at once and the beauty of the baby steps
is it's focused and so while while
you're going to be inv 15% while paying
off the mortgage as soon as that thing's
knocked out you're you can weigh up that
investment and you remember you also
freed up 500 bucks from that
mortgage right would you suggest that I
just stop my 401k for two years pay off
my mortgage and then get back on it no
just that's two years of compound growth
you'd lose um the one thing that I would
do you may want to pause temporarily to
get that emergency fund in place mhm
because getting 20% of your income back
to save up that 25k that's going to
protect you cuz a lot of times what
happens bill is people have one of these
emergencies uh later in life and it
might be a $112,000 emergency you don't
have $112,000 so what do you do you go
into debt moving you backwards and it
halts your wealth building
Journey okay and that's baby step three
to have six months
exactly all right and Bill I'm going to
send you a copy of my new book Breaking
Free from broke it'll walk you through
all these baby steps it'll talk about
wealth it'll talk about investing uh in
mortgages all that stuff is in there and
I hope it gives you some um confidence
for your retirement but I feel good just
looking at a calculator J sometimes the
numbers is exactly what you need it is
you know I think about that statistic it
says 52% of Americans feel that they're
not prepared for retirement or that they
don't have enough saved and I sometimes
think that that that fear and that
anxiety could be remedied if people just
looked at the actual numbers instead of
assuming they don't have it or assuming
they can't do it when you start plugging
number real numbers into that calculator
it can give you peace and it can help
you see what you need to be doing so
that you can have the retirement that
you want so that's a good word knowledge
is power and listen it's not too late
for you America if you're 51 and you
only have 100 Grand in retirement it's
not too late look at Bill he's already
about a millionaire and he's going to be
doing just fine 10 15 years from now
when he retires that puts this hour of
the ramsy show in the
books
[Applause]
[Music]
w
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Jake bhaw this hour the number to call
is
8825 5225 don't wear it out you call in
and we'll talk about your life and your
money Elizabeth kicks us off in Atlanta
Georgia Elizabeth how can we help today
hey thank you guys so much for answering
absolutely well Austin answered we he
just then patched you through to us so
you can thank Austin for that he's a
good man thank you Austin and thank you
for having me on um so I am currently a
college student and I am getting all of
my college paid for by a family member
right now and I'm renting again through
that family member and I would I'm in
school for interior design and I do want
to get into real estate after I graduate
so I'm trying to think of a way that I
can get set in the right foot after I
graduate per se so I would like
to propose the idea of buying a house to
this family member and then possibly
buying it from them after I graduate and
I just want to know if that's a good
idea hold on they buy it for you they
buy it I live in it until I graduate and
then once I start making a steady income
buy it from them that is a tall order uh
Elizabeth it is it is it is it is but
with the rent I am paying right now
buying a house would be cheaper in the
long row but you're not buying a h hold
on I'm sorry I I don't mean any harm so
you said it's the same family member so
the same family member that is allowing
like paying your rent now and paying
your way to college you mean to tell me
you're going to go to them and say hey
why don't you also buy a house for me to
live in and then the assumption is that
you'll buy it from them because you just
get to decide when they're going to sell
their house and who they're going to
sell it
to well this I mean this is the proposal
I I no why not just you get yourself in
a position to buy a house why do they
have to be
involved because straight out of college
I won't I don't have but you don't have
to be able to buy a house straight out
of college be
trying to set myself up in the right way
yes but you're not the one setting
yourself up you're trying to have you're
trying to have somebody else prop you up
and what what does well for us as adults
is when we form and craft our way
through life financially listen I'm
happy some going to college Deb free
right that's great but once you graduate
listen buying a house is not just kind
of like a willy-nilly thing hey why
don't you buy this house for me I'll
live in it and then when I'm good and
ready you can sell it to me that's um I
don't think you understand kind of how
how much you're inserting yourself into
that person's life and deciding the
timeline on their financial investment I
and I get that you don't realize that
but what George and I are trying to get
at is you you don't have to we all have
this checklist in our mind of I I I go
to school I get my degree I get my big
girl job I get my car I get my house I
get married I have my kid and it's like
we're trying to check these things off
the list to tell oursel that that's
makes us successful and it doesn't have
to go that quickly the fact that you're
in school without student loans that is
a major win the fact that you are going
to graduate without student loans major
win and the fact that you are going to
get a job in your field that's thing one
and then you're going to be able to
sustain rent and understand what it just
feels like to have that responsibility
because I don't mean any harm but you
haven't had to assume any financial
responsibility yet so this idea that
you're just I have with what I have I
did I did live by myself for two years
years with no Financial stability from
anybody else and then once I decided to
go to school then I was given the
opportunity to have my life paid for but
I did I did rent a place by myself 100%
on my own for two years before I came to
school good I'm glad you did that I
think that you should do that again when
you come out now with this this is the
job I want I'm in the career field I
want pick a place in town where you want
to live there is a big part to that
having the 3 to 6 months saved up and
just walking through this and being you
Elizabeth and standing on your own two
feet in no world would I think would I
say that it's a good idea to say um who
who is the family member by the
way it's a grandparent no way what I say
grandma grandpa will you buy a
house worth x amount of dollars and me
be the renter paying full rent and
because here's the thing we're I'm just
assuming are are are you renting at cost
or are they charging you a real rent
where they're able to make some money on
this
investment that's that's something I
would have to talk about with the
grandparents that's a big deal so for
you to even make the Assumption listen
I'll just rent at cost you won't make
any money on the
renter you know and whatever it
appreciates whenever I'm ready I'll buy
it because they might be ready they
might want to hold the property longer
like what if that's the case that
they're like listen this the Market's
not great right now we understand that
you want to buy it but it's not great
for us there's so many factors in
volatil
there that have the ability to make you
know the relationship not the best that
it can be yeah how many more years do
you have until you graduate I'm supposed
to graduate within two years okay so you
graduate with an interior design degree
you said you wanted to go into real
estate as in be a real estate agent no
just I want to I want to own property
okay so you just want to be a
homeowner that but I also want to be
able to own other properties lots of
properties
okay you want to go full Monopoly here
all right and is the goal to be working
full-time in interior
design yes and so you'd start off
working for an interior
designer I imagine and then work your
way up to maybe starting your own
interior design company one day that is
the Hope what's starting salary like
when you come out of college what does
an interior designer in your area
earn it it really just depends I don't
plan on staying in the area but it can
start anywhere from 50k a year
to maybe 80 okay 50 to 80 so let's say
65 so you come out you're making 65
you've got no
debt tell me more about your personal
financial
situation it about my financial
situation
yeah um I have a paid off car I have
$2,000 of my own separate money I've
been doing commissions like little side
hustles and saving that on my own so
I've got 2,000 saved up own personal
money and it's working its way up right
now and what's your rent right now do
you pay rent my rent right now is I my
my grandparent does it's $2,500 a month
well you just said the the mortgage is
cheaper than
rent if I was to get a house that was or
this is all very hypothetical but if
there was to be a house to that was
bought then that is assuming that you're
paying it at costs that you're not going
to That's My worry is there's a lot of
assumptions here and one is that renting
is is just I might as well get a
mortgage $2,000 in rent $2,000 in
mortgage it doesn't work like that
because there's property taxes there's
Insurance there's maintenance there's
all the surprise repairs and you have
$2,000 to your name I'd be scared out of
my mind if I had two grand and I was a
homeowner well she going to live in the
parents house until she's she's going to
ask the grandparents to buy I would work
your tail off get a down payment and
work on just continuing to stack up cash
and when you're ready to be a homeowner
you'll be a homeowner but I would not
try to Leap Frog this and shortcut your
way there and ruin relationships over it
your grandma has done enough this is
such a blessing and I would let that be
your setup for your future and Grandma
if you're listening don't do this deal
cuz you might be listening to Grandma
granny and grandpappy don't do this deal
it's not a good deal this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camell joined by Jade warshaw
open phones at
8825 5225 you call us we'll talk about
your life and your money uh Jade we were
talking during the break and I thought
this might be good uh content to talk
about on the show what's that I got an
email from the Social Security
Department with my like yearly statement
okay so I thought all right I'm a young
buck but I'll open this up let me see
what's inside uh this bad boy uhhuh and
it was pretty interesting to see
how much money the government thinks I
will be given when I Am The Ripe age of
62 or 70 and I wanted to break this down
because we get this question frequently
on the show people are asking hey when
should I take Social Security will it
even be there for me note on that part
there's actually a spot in the document
where they're they know people are
concerned about this so like hey we want
to give you confidence in in your future
and retirement so click this PDF to show
how we'll be there for you well here was
the the rousing uh confidence
booster we know that um at least until
2034 the money will be there yeah and I
was like okay 203 that's that's 10 years
from now so 10 years from now they're
not going to have 100% of the funding to
keep social going and we know this and
they encourage me by saying Hey listen
even if nothing changes we'll still be
able to pay 80% of each benefit due CU
that's fair because I paid into this
thing for my whole life for them to then
discount it but keep in mind that the
benefit was only at a portion of your
exactly so they're giving you 80% of
what was already what was only a 40%
benefit to begin with so uh that we're
at 2.83 trillion in the fund in the
trust funds as it stands today and so
that's why um I encourage people
especially the younger Generations do
not rely on this this is icing on the
cake and I talked about this in my new
book Breaking Free from bro Jade can I
tell you what I wrote hit me research
from the Fed reveals 26% of non-retired
Americans have 0 in any kind of
retirement
account that's one in four non-retired
people this is not great and in research
from Ramsey Solutions 48% have less than
10 grand saved in retirement so that's
going to get you about what 3 months
into retirement if you're lucky that's
so then people are going well Jade at
least all have social security uh well
we just showed you how that's not going
to be enough to get by here's the real
numbers the average monthly benefit in
2023 from Social Security was around
1,700 $ a month try living on that and
you'll see why we call it social
insecurity that's approaching the
poverty line that's 1,700 bucks a month
and by the way that's the average Jade
some people get less than $900 a
month wow and here's here's the last
stat 52% of workers have never stopped
to calculate how much money they'll even
need in retirement so half of them are
just yoloing and fingers crossed head in
the sand yet again let someone else
worry about it yet again assuming that
the government will be there to handle
them financially listen I I will tell
anybody who will listen you need to if
you want to be thriving you want to be
thriving during retirement years not
just surviving and scratching by and and
then there's the scam I'm going to just
call a scam George where it's like okay
if I take Social Security early at 62
I'm only going to get it this much so
I'm going to wait till I'm fully aged
you know where I can get the full
benefit but if you wait even longer you
get more money this is what we need to
talk about yes and this is we do need to
talk about it because I did the math for
you I just talked with the uh I think it
was CNBC I was talking to them and I was
saying listen if you don't have to like
if you're going to work Beyond 62 start
taking social security you know your boy
is going to take that money out the day
it's available invest it George give him
the math okay I crunched the numbers for
you cuz you know I'm a nerd and I need
the numbers so at age 62 if I took out
my benefit and I started getting that
every month and I invested that whole
portion let's just say into a taxable
brokerage account not even retirement
account and let's assume 10% rate of
return okay from age 62 to age 80
starting from 0 in this account I would
have $1.45
million wow just from extra money that I
took immediately when I could take it
right yes now if I wait till 70 of
course people go well George you're
going to have you know a lot more money
coming in from Social Security every
month right yeah but I also lost out on
eight years of compound growth so even
investing the larger amount for 10 years
from age 70 to age 80 mhm at age 80 I
now have $921,000 in that account listen
so that's a difference get this because
I took social security as soon as I
could and invested it instead of waiting
till 70 it's a difference of over half a
million dollars guys to my netw worth
and to what I can pass on to my
grandchildren what I want to say cuz
George you laid that out perfectly but I
know there's still people who feel this
weird sense of fear about even
considering that as an OP option it's
like well the government's giving me
that money it's for my retirement I'm
like number one the government's not
giving you anything that was your money
that you paid in and you're only getting
a portion of it back let's be clear
about that GI the government doesn't
gift anything it's just redistributing
all of our money yeah you're getting
back your money you gave it to them and
they invested it poorly at like a 2.2%
return and now that's part of the reason
here that we're not having enough to
fund everything they're giving your
money back to you so you can take it and
do whatever you want with it and what
George is suggesting and what I'm
suggesting is invested invested in
something that gets better than a 2.2%
return because at the end of the day
they were only going to provide 40% of
the lifestyle you've been used to living
and after 20 and after 2034 that 40%
goes down
80% that's crazy that's critical this is
why it's called social insecurity get
this camera on me right now here here's
the deal America go fund yourself I said
it live on the Ramsey Show do not rely
on the government to take care of you
with this terrible plan especially those
that are younger cuz it may not even be
around and if it is it's going to be
pennies compared to what your parents
got and their pensions and all these
wonderful ways they were able to just
not sa for retirement but it's going to
be on us Jade and that's why we tell
people invest early get out of debt get
the emergency fund get to investing
compound interest is your best friend
and if you just do the simple thing be
the tortoise instead of the hair that's
right avoid the crypto and well my bud
said I need to get an annuity and a
whole life insurance policy and I saw
this rapper on this Tik Tok video said
this is what the wealthy do just invest
in your 401k I promise it's not a scam
80% of the millionaires we studied uh
said the 401K was the number one vehicle
yeah your retirement employer plan it is
so boring and yet it works when you just
invest in mutual funds overtime the S&P
500 the overall stock market has
returned 10 to 12% since its Inception
that's the yeah it's almost like you
boil it down to just the if you can in
the course of your lifespan you know we
strike out when we're 1820 and most of
us are going to work until we're 65 God
willing maybe even 70 if you want to but
if you can do three things if you can
just pay off your debt and live a
debt-free
lifestyle if you can and so that you're
entering retirement without Consumer
Debt then if you can do one better and
and invest monthly regularly when the
time comes so you've made it a habit of
investing and if you can enter in
retirement without a home mortgage like
three goals you have in life if you can
that you are golden and when you do that
George you don't need as much of a nest
egg if you can enter into retirement
without Consumer Debt and without
Mortgage Debt suddenly this need to have
all this giant money you're like okay
I've I've eliminated so much of the
payment so much of what's need that that
you needed before that you don't need to
have you know when you decrease your
risk you increase your peace that's
right it's that simple and so when you
do that and luckily for my wife and I we
decided to do that early we thought what
would it be like in our 30s to have no
mortgage payment to be investing for a
future now bringing our daughter into
this world yeah it's just a different
way to live we're not as worried about
inflation and what if there's a crash
and what if the pandemic we just get to
live our life with peace that's right
you don't have payments and that's what
I want for everyone out there and
investing consistently everyone's
arguing about net worth and what right
your home equity I'm going listen I'm
not touching this money we're fine we
got margin in our day-to-day life until
I'm 62 and tap into Social Security and
those investment accounts and Lord
willing we won't need much of it yeah
what we're saying is a good man leaves
an inheritance to his children's
children and you can't do that if Social
Security was your
only out that's it like you you just
stopped and said okay I'm done making
money I have no assets and Social
Security is there you you can't leave
anybody to anything to any r on your
kids we take enough calls in the show
where relationships are destroyed
because parents are relying on the kids
the kids are relying on the parents they
didn't communicate they didn't invest
for retirement and they're calling us a
65 going we have nothing saved what do
we do get a time machine I mean there's
not a lot you can do you can get out of
debt but folks can break the cycle today
there are people who can start breaking
that cycle today be one of those people
wealth gained hastily will dwindle but
whoever gathers little by little will
increase it hey be the tortoise be a
Crockpot in a world full of microwaves
my friends this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
w
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Jade warshaw and
in the lobby on the Deb free stage we've
got Tony and HIPAA how you guys doing
doing great well I can tell by your
Ramsay swag t-shirts live like no one
else debt free you're here to do a debt
free scream that is correct you guys
from Hamond Indiana wonderful and how
much debt did you pay off
$31,000 wow wow and not a penny
less okay and how long did that take
four years and S months woo nice wow and
what was the range of income during that
time we started at $60,000 and ended at
$123,000 let's go that'll like that what
do you guys do for a living I'm a a
flight attendant and a recent FC CMT
graduate Financial coach graduate nice
went through our financial coach
training that's cool yes yes and I'm an
assistant principal wonderful okay so
let's talk about this
$31,000 what kind of debt was this oh it
was student loans hey primarily
primarily student Lo wow 180 I was the
smart one I she's like I have no problem
pointing at you for this I have a
semester of high quality college
education so it's all his master's
degrees so a lot of Education what else
was in the mix 401K loans two
phones uh two iPhones two cars credit
cards um all of that wow just the normal
typical American lifestyle yes yes yes
so just a little poper of Deb if you
will yeah and it kind of started when um
we actually had our um second oldest son
uh when my wife had him then we ended up
um I ended up getting a a torn Achilles
uh a month after she had him so we were
both off work for um and I was off for
at least 6 months wow and then my wife
couldn't couldn't go back to work
because at that time we she was taking
care of two babies unfortunately me and
my son who was the bigger baby goodness
I would say he was okay than oh okay
okay wow okay so four years seven months
ago I mean something took a turn
what happened I was sitting on the couch
just tired and um the Holy Spirit tapped
on my shoulder and said
um you have a book that can change this
and um uh as a flight attendant I used
to go in the front and sit with the
pilots cuz they had a lot of money so I
used to ask them a lot of questions and
one of them told me to get um Total
Money Makeover huh and I got it in my
early 20s but I didn't need it at the
time but it said in my um Library all
that time so I went to the where our
books were and I looked and I found the
book and I read it in a day and gave it
to him and he read it and that's what
started that's started W so Tony she
comes to you with this book she just
read in a day she's looking like crazy
eyed over this plan I'm guessing and
what was your response were you like
okay honey sounds good so initially yes
I said okay honey it sounds good with no
intentions of reading it like like she
did MH um but once I picked it up and
actually looked through it and started
it's such an easy read that's right and
it just and it was just so
understandable and relatable and then
just looking listening to the other
testimonials it it I end up reading it
within uh not not one day maybe two days
but but yeah I definitely got on board
right away wow so hypa when you started
talking about there's clearly emotion
there is the emotion oh my gosh this
book changed our life is the emotion I
wish I had started sooner tell me about
what you're feeling in that moment um I
felt like um God asked me to do
something important for my family and um
there was a lot of death happening um my
mom and my grandma and seven people died
on my Mo mother's side of the family
gosh and I felt like before I died I
wanted to do something special for my
family and um well at that point you're
like life is short what are we doing we
got to get on this thing I was unsure
about what um what I was going to leave
what Legacy I would leave behind and so
um this was something you could control
you can control this yes you guys Chang
your family trade 4 years and 7 months
301,000 paid off what was the hardest
part of this journey cuz that's not a
short amount of time to sacrifice um I
would say cooking cooking every day
listen that's the word our budget in the
beginning was $50 to eat out so we went
to Golden Corral during lunch hours cuz
we couldn't afford the dinner prices in
once a month and so and just um the
people that I thought would be here to
see it they um passed on before um it
happened and um that adversity just
really made us um stronger spiritually
and stronger marriage yeah oh I bet most
definitely and I just wanted to add add
to that I think that um neither one of
us coming from a family tree that had a
lot of money and not so much just the
money aspect but the knowledge of it
that's right and so that was the key
takeaway just from for me um or us as as
a as a unit just wanting to get the
knowledge so we could prepare our
children to have them you know to have a
brighter financial future as well
absolutely what a crew and I'm sure they
I mean they're old enough they saw mom
and dad they're going to remember this
journey most definitely the the uh the
Goodwill runs we were in Thrift stars
like crazy I mean there was a lot of uh
sacrifice but it it was worth it it was
well worth it and um I do want to add
this um we paid off all of the uh debt
the cars we sold cars we bought $2,000
cars $3,000 cars during the journey and
then we just had two student loans left
we paid off one student loan for 13,000
and we had a $45,000 student loan and
then
$123,000 left and I was watching Anthony
O'Neal and it said if you have student
loans do this before October
31st and I did it and um we went from 44
qualified payments for student loan
forgiveness to
125 so that whole all of those got
knocked out it got forgiven all of that
and so God not only gave us something to
do but helped us get there you guys were
faithful every step of the way a Quantum
Leap and that's
amazing exciting who are your
cheerleaders um uh each other most
definitely each other our Anthem Church
um our children yes and God yes that'll
do you know what and then we had um I do
want to shout out um uh Damian Harmon
the Harmon family so they did um they
knew about our journey as as well um
Pete McAdams uh close buddy of mine they
both live here actually in Tennessee as
well so those people I know we spoke to
a lot about it who was right there with
us from the very beginning and just told
us to kept pressing keep pressing yeah
and um it just um it felt good it feels
good it definitely feels oh I bet it
does so what's next you're debt free how
are you celebrating um so we having uh
oh we're having a a de free party hey
yeah we're going to have a debt free
party we're still working out the
particulars on when exactly um cuz it's
it's still it's such a surreal moment um
just being able to do something that
we've never seen done yeah but then also
do it for our children to let them know
that their def Destiny uh affirmation
starts here with this moment and this
will be the new chapter in their lives
in our lives as a get get the kids up
here what are the names and ages okay we
have Talon 13 we have anahi and today is
her birthday she turned get up on stage
happy
birday and then Ali she6 oh my good well
they get to scream with you they were a
part of this process and they're
celebrating Mom and Dad's Freedom cuz
that's freedom for them too that's
changing the family tree let's do this
thing y'all ready ready right we got a
living give box for you including Baby
Steps millionaires Total Money Makeover
and Financial Peace University so use it
or pass it on to someone else to
Kickstart their Journey you guys are an
inspiration all right we got Tony High
the whole gang
$331,000 in years 7 months making 60 all
the way to 123 Count it down let's hear
a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 we're Deb
free now that's a scream George with the
matching better than I deserve t-shirts
and to live like no one else t-shirts
wow that's generational curse is being
broken listen you heard it in their
voices that was a Deb free scream if I
ever heard one my goodness woo that'll
put a pep in my step I got some Shivers
on my spine this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
our scripture of the Day psalm 3723 and
24 the Lord makes firm the steps of the
one who Delights in him though he May
stumble he will not fall for the Lord
upholds him with his
hand in other news Slash from Guns and
Roses once said no one expects the rug
to be yanked out from underneath them
life-changing events usually don't
announce themselves who knew that's the
kind of wildly varying entertainment you
get on this show from Proverbs and Psalm
to slash there we go well Jade I don't
know if you've been keeping up with the
news uh the Grammys just happened the
big game is coming up this weekend
everyone's talking about Taylor Swift
instead of the big game but the big news
is right here on the ramsy show you
ready for this tell me more we just
launched a new ramsy trusted National
partner that can help you find the right
health insurance really I know not the
news you were expecting I didn't know
tell me more well we all know health
insurance it's not the most exciting or
fun thing on people's list but you know
what it is fun having the right health
insurance when you need it facts I mean
the amount of people going bankrupt in
medical bills is frightening and so you
know to get a load off your mind
protection for your hard- earned money
not panicking at the first side of the
medical bill that's my idea of fun at
least partially and it's why we are so
excited to have a new partner called
Health Trust financial and this isn't
really new cuz here's why our team has
worked with Health Trust Financial folks
a lot over the years and a bunch of
their independent agents have actually
been serving Ramsey fans for more than
two decades now first they were part of
our endorse local providers program then
as Ramsey trusted pros and while a lot
of health insurance companies out there
care more about premiums Than People
Health Trust Financial cares about
educating you saving you money and
shopping different providers to find you
the health insurance you need and
they've done such a great job working
with our fans that our team decided to
expand this relationship and make Health
Trust Financial the only health
insurance company we recommend here at
Ramsey that's High Praise listen that's
you got to do right by people for a long
time and treat them well and treat our
fans well because trust is all we have
here Ramsey that's what we're all about
so the fact that you guys have a new uh
company out there you can reach out to
for all of your health insurance needs
Health Trust Financial that's huge they
know their stuff and they want to help
you protect your wallet from unexpected
medical costs so if you need help
figuring out the best health insurance
for you and your family be sure to check
them out at healthtrust
financial.com very cool very cool
partnership all right let's go to the
phones Chris is up next in Myrtle Beach
South Carolina Chris welcome to the show
hey how are you guys doing doing well
how can we help
today um my wife loves your nails Jade
by the way the color of your nails thank
you it's always Jade and never George
what's wrong with my nails
Chris I love them thank you and your
watch thank you appreciate that how can
we help um so we're looking to relocate
here uh mid year probably June July um
and I've done some math to where I could
probably safely get us out of debt with
the equity within our home
um and be debt free when we move but my
wife is a little sksh she wants to be
able to buy right away when we relocate
where are you relocating to uh
Pennsylvania okay is this for
work um just better lifestyle overall um
the tourist town really isn't for us or
touristy income so to speak seasonal
seasonal positions that kind of thing or
you know it's tough to get what's in
Pennsylvania what drove you guys
there um that's where I'm originally
from um we moved down here my parents
before I you know became of age and
didn't have a choice um moved here um I
met my wife we've got a family here um
but we would we've been back there to
visit you know over the years she likes
it you know obviously I liked it when I
was up there um I would have stayed but
I didn't have a choice at that time so
is the assumption that if you bought a
place you live in the area that you grew
up or the area that you
know correct um even even if we you know
the way I want to do it with renting we
would rent somewhere within that within
that
vicinity I got to tell you I'm I'm I I
would vote for the rent in the vicinity
that you think you want to live because
times have changed out there I imagine
since you live there true
that and so part part of this is
financial I mean if how much Equity do
you guys have in the
house
um we owe 140 and we could sell for
roughly
275 okay so net of fees you're looking
at what 110
120 um based on my calculations with
transfer taxes and things like that um
about 101 okay so let's say you walk
away with 101 how much debt do you
have um about
48,000 that's including a a vehicle so
okay so we clear debt and that leaves
you with 53 total to your
name uh let's see here unless you have
money in
savings uh I don't so it would be yeah
yeah what you said that's correct okay
so let's call that your emergency fund
plus a little bit of down payment
money um so my idea was um from the 101
and the the debt um we could take 20
about
26,400 um rent on average for uh the
space we would need there as of right
now is about 2,200 that's on the the
higher
end um take that for a year 26400 pay
that up front um and then we would why
pay up
front we could then take that 264 that
we would pay up front and we could save
that over the entirety of the year to
make that our down payment on the home
that we would look you know to purchase
within that year hold on next year are
you saying I I want to make sure I'm
following you are you saying you want to
pay your rent
Upfront for six months and then take cor
for a year correct to
who we would pay the lease out in full
for the full year as opposed to paying
it monthly I wouldn't do that I would
just pay Mon and you have the money
sitting in savings already because what
if something what if something happens
and you're like we're Renning here the
guy above above us smokes pot and we
can't get out of this like what if it
what if there's a complication are you
not concerned that it could be a pain in
the butt to get your money
back um I hadn't really thought that far
into it that's part the reason why I
just think there's too much unnecessary
risk in that and no benefit so I would
just pay the normal payment 2200 a month
what's your take-home pay as a
family um as a family about 950 a week
wait so it's only less than four grand a
month yeah about 33 I make 49 salary a
year well you're but here's the problem
your rent is over 50% of your take-home
pay so you guys can't afford to live in
this
area right but we
would what's the
plan uh we would you know we'd have that
savings from we would be able to pull
our six months draining your savings is
not a sustainable option even for a year
because then you're still not in a
position to buy a house
20 grand down is not going to get you
very far in today's market so I think we
need to rethink this whole thing and if
your income is not going to double in
the next 6 months to a year we need to
rethink where we're living and what our
situation is I love the idea of you
selling this place to get out of your
debt and have some money in the bank but
we're not in a position to go move
somewhere where the rent's 2200 bucks
what about your wife working how old are
the
kids um she
works uh full-time in the summertime
over the summer months and then
part-time inside gigs over the over the
wintertime months when it's not as as
busy at her job did you include that in
the 49k did you include
that that's correct oh you did I'm sorry
no that's just that's just my my salary
the 49k okay so what what is her like
what does she bring in regularly if you
had to average it out what does she make
in a
year um in a year we last year we
grossed
569 9900
okay
56,000 okay um we still need to get this
so she's making 6,000 bucks a year gross
which is my what I'm getting at is what
about her cuz if you if you tell me hey
I make 49,000 and then with her money
it's 56 I'm like okay she made $7,000 in
a year gross that means net y'all didn't
bring hardly any in so what I'm getting
at is is there a way that she can make
real steady money to contribute to this
that's why I asked how old the kids are
cuz I kind of wanted to see what what
that's like real quick
right they're they're all school age
kids 17 13 and that's the key to crack
this code if you guys are salary in
order to afford 2,200 a month you need a
take-home pay of about eight8 Grand or
at least yeah she needs to work and
double match what you
make right but with the relocation she
would be making right around the same
amount as me so that would put us at
right around 80 to 90 a year i' I'd
crunch these numbers hard Chris before
you make this move right now I have some
hesitation that this is the time but we
need to get the income up and you need
to find a cheaper place to rent and you
need to get rid of this debt this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show